hi i'm allah and in this presentation
i'm going to talk about
limitations of noisy quantum circuits
and
the space overhead necessary for fault
iron quantum computation
this is based on a joint work with omar
falzi and alexander muller hermes
as you know quantum resources have been
proven to provide a considerable
advantage in certain computational tasks
but quantum systems are
extremely fragile and quantum
computation is uh inherently noisy
and that's why when the first quantum
algorithms were discovered in the 90s
people were very excited but at the same
time
mostly skeptical about whether we can
ever actually implement these algorithms
and at the time quantum error correction
seemed to be simply impossible because
the ideas from classical error
correction
did not seem to be useful to protect
quantum information
and this was until uh shore and steen
introduced the first quantum error
correcting codes in the mid 90s
and
this was the beginning of the theory of
quantum error correction and fault
tolerance as we know today
perhaps one of the most influential
results in the theory of quantum
computation is the the fault iron
threshold theorem
which states that you can do arbitrarily
long quantum computations
uh on a noisy quantum computer as long
as the noise level in your quantum
computer is below a constant level
which is known as the threshold value
of course i haven't defined what i mean
by the noise level or or how we
model noise on a quantum computer
and in fact the threshold value actually
depends on the details of the the model
we consider both in noise model and the
circuit model
but this is great and what is even more
remarkable is that we can achieve what
tolerance
at a very reasonable cost
so there exists a faltering scheme
which maps any circuit of with n and
depth t
to a faltering implementation circuit of
beat
and prime and depth t prime
such that the overhead is only poly
logarithmic in n and t
and
we define the space overhead as the
ratio and prime over n
and
the time overhead is defined as
t prime over t
okay so this is very nice the overhead
seems very reasonable
but then why is it that we haven't been
able to perform more interesting quantum
computations yet
well one of the problems is that the
overhead
of the known schemes is still too much
for today's technology and
our implementations
are still too noisy
so broadly speaking the results and
fault tolerance are in two main
directions
the first class of results are
achievability results which aim at
introducing more efficient fault
tolerance schemes with lower overhead
and a higher tolerance to noise
there are a lot of results in this
direction and i have listed a tiny
number of them here
in particular more recently goddessman
showed that assuming
a good quantum error correcting code
satisfying certain properties exist then
the space overhead can be asymptotically
brought down to a consonant
and later on fawzi at all
proved that quantum expander codes
actually satisfy these desired
properties and actually showed that
constant space overhead is indeed
achievable
however in contrast to the threshold
theorem which applies to arbitrarily
long circuits the scheme achieving a
constant overhead only works for
circuits which have depth at most
polynomial the width
and
so this this motivates the following
question
given a noise model how does the
necessary overhead grow as a function of
the circuit size
so the second class of results on
quantum fault tolerance are
concerned with questions of this type
so these are impossibility results which
study limitations of noisy quantum
computation and fault tolerance
and
here our understanding is very limited
and this is partly because uh it's not
really easy to define what a fall town
scheme is
uh so in this work we studied the
question i mentioned earlier
and uh in doing so we tried to address
some of the limitations of the earlier
results which i'll discuss in detail
in the next slide
okay
so i've been talking about noisy quantum
circuits
so let me define
what our model is
so
uh in our model a quantum circuit is
simply a an ordered sequence of quantum
channels
or completely positive and trace
preserving linear maps
acting on a potentially non-trivial
input system
we use the term time to refer to the
vertical cuts between layers of
computation as shown in this figure
the number of qubits may vary in
different time steps so in each time
step a fresh ancelor qubits may be added
qubits may be measured and the
measurement outcomes
may be processed and the next operations
may depend on this information
and for reasons which become clear in
the next slide we distinguish between
classical and quantum subsystems
so in this figure we we denote the
classical subsystems by double lines
so
for the noise model we consider iid
noise
where in every time step every qubit is
subject to some noise channel n
and
an important feature of our result
compared to
the previous
results on limitations of noisy quantum
circuits is that
we allow classical computation to be
noiseless
and this is important because today
we can do classical computation with
practically perfect accuracy
and in fact in our model
classical computation is free and
noiseless
so we use the notation iid sub n of c
to denote the quantum channel
corresponding to the noisy
implementation of a circuit c
in the iid noise model where the noise
is modeled by this qubit channel n
so we are ready to state our main result
a unitary quantum channel is a channel
that conjugates its input by a unitary
operator
so a unitary channel is not an
interesting noise channel especially in
our
circuit model
because we can perfectly cancel the
noise by basically
applying the inverse unitary operator
so our main result is the following
so let n be a non-unitary cubic channel
then for any fault iron scheme against
the iid
and noise model
the number of physical qubits or or n
prime is at least the maximum of the
following two bounds
the first bound is
alpha n times log t where alpha n is
just some constant only depending on the
channel n
and the second lower bound
is uh the inverse of the quantum
capacity of n times
of the channel n
times uh n
so the quantum capacity is the basically
the the maximum rate at which quantum
information can be transmitted
using
this noise channel n
so in fact if n has zero quantum
capacity or the space overhead is less
than the inverse of the quantum capacity
of n
then uh
you cannot achieve fault tolerance even
for a single term step
and uh
as we'll see this is a direct
consequence of our model of fault
tolerance which i'll define in the next
slide
so for the rest of this stock i'm just
going to focus on the first bound
alpha n times log t
okay
now in order to prove a statement about
faltering schemes one first needs to
define what a four turn scheme is
and as i said earlier it's really
difficult to provide a definition which
captures all the different aspects of
fault tolerance
here
we consider a very natural model of all
tolerance with minimal assumptions that
as far as we know
are satisfied by most if not all the
known schemes
according to our model uh photons scheme
is only required to be capable of
implementing any arbitrary circuit on
encoded data in some code space that is
associated with the faltering scheme
more precisely
a faltron's scheme
is a family of circuit encodings indexed
by l associated with a family of quantum
error correcting codes with encoding and
decoding maps e and d
again indexed by l
such that the following condition is
satisfied
uh given any input circuit c
and any accuracy parameter epsilon
a photon scheme should output an
encoding of c from the family for
sufficiently large l
such that the encoded circuit is fault
tolerant in the following sense
so uh if we consider the quantum channel
corresponding to first applying the
encoder
and then the noisy implementation of the
encoded circuit
and then followed by the decoder
uh the overall quantum channel is
epsilon close to the quantum channel
corresponding to the original circuit c
so here
we take the induced trace distance as
our
distance measure
note that the encoder and decoder are
assumed to be ideal in our model
to understand the definition better you
can think of alternate schemes based on
concatenation
and in this case the index l corresponds
to
the level of concatenation
so in order to prove our main result
uh we prove the following lemma which is
our main technical contribution
so we fix the qubit noise channel n and
we consider a quantum circuit
of
depth t and with n
such that
the registers in each time step are
partitioned into a and b subsystems and
the circuit is only allowed to act
locally on a and b subsystems
and it is only allowed to communicate
classically between the a and b parts
so for any such quantum circuit
we show that the amount of entanglement
between the a and b parts is decreased
by a factor of 1 minus p to the n
where p is a constant only depending on
the channel n
here we let row i denote the state of
the circuit after i time steps and as
our measure of entanglement we use chi
sap
which is defined for state rule b as the
the minimum chi-square divergence from
the set of several states
with respect to the partition a b
and
the chi 2 divergence between two density
operators one sigma
is defined
by this equation
so here's our lemma
uh from the lemma we can prove the
following corollary
uh what does this caller say it says
that for any non-unital cubit channel n
there exists a constant p depending on
the under channel n
uh so the same constant as in the lemma
such that any circuit of depth t and
width n
with t at least one over p to the two n
is not capable of preserving even a
single qubit
this is true even if the qubit is
encoded perfectly in some quantum error
correcting code and we have an ideal
decoder
and so
uh our main theorem follows from
discovery with alpha n
equal to one over two log one over p
so i'm going to at least give you an
idea of how we prove that them i
mentioned in the previous slide
but before that let me discuss some of
the earlier results on noisy quantum
computation that are
relevant to our work
so uh ben or ethanol study noisy quantum
computation with no supply of fresh
ancelor qubits
uh similar to us they consider the iid
noise model with different qubit noise
channels ends
uh in the case of deep rising noise uh
they show a logarithmic bound and the
maximum length of computation
uh the proof is based on an entropy
production argument
and
so in in our model uh we allow fresh
ancelor qubits to be introduced during
the computation
and we also allow intermediate
measurements and this allows us to
remove the entropy produced by the noise
in each time step and as a result
arguments of this type
are no longer applicable in our model
and then for dephasing noise they prove
a polynomial or bound and upper bound on
the maximal computation time
their argument for this case has a
similar favor to our proof
but
it's in a more restricted circuit model
uh with uh no fresh ancelors available
and
uh finally
for amplitude damping noise
uh they show how to do quantum
computation for an exponential time
and they actually conjecture that an
exponential upper bound should also hold
and they pose it as an open question
here in this work we prove an
exponential upper bound even when fresh
ancelor cubits are available
so our upper bound is exponential in n
plus m
where m is
the maximum number of ancillars that are
used
in different time specs
another relevant result is a work by
raginski
who studies the same problem in a
different model
uh in his noise model he assumes that a
fixed
strictly contracted noise channel
acts collectively on all the qubits in
the quantum circuit after each
computational step
so a quantum channel is said to be
strictly contracted
if
the channel strictly decreases the
distance between any two input states
so he showed that for any circuit
involving only unitary gates the
distance between any two input states
decays by a constant factor in each time
step
hardwork can be viewed as an extension
of this result in in particular
we show how to apply a similar reasoning
when the noise is given by tensor powers
of arbitrary
non-unitary cubic channels
and we also take into account a
free and
noiseless classical computation
then we have a sequence of results on
noisy quantum computation that
uh are maybe not directly relevant to
our work
these results prove statements of the
following form
if the noise level in a quantum circuit
is higher than a constant level
then the circuit is useless after a
bounded number of time steps
now
if you recall the statement of the
threshold theorem
it said that
you can do arbitrarily long quantum
computations if the noise level is below
the threshold
so these results apply only to noise
levels above the threshold value in fact
they prove upper bounds on the threshold
value
whereas in our case we do not put any
restriction on the power of noise and
this is exactly the reason why
we can translate our results
to a statement about the overhead of
photon schemes
another point is that
in these works
there is no distinction between
classical and quantum subsystems and
classical systems are also subject to
the same noise
[Music]
these results also consider different
measures of uselessness for example
uh rasboro shows that under strong deep
rising noise after a logarithmic number
of time steps the output of any circuit
uh will be basically independent of the
input
uh camp at all also prove a similar
statement
uh although in a in a slightly different
model
however
if we allow noiseless classical
computation then these statements uh no
longer hold
even for arbitrarily long circuits for
example
you can consider a circuit where a
subset of qubits are measured in the
first time step
and they're kept
noise free
and output at the end of the circuit
then the output is no longer independent
of the of the inputs
uh and finally
these results are mostly focused on
depolarizing noise uh with the exception
of the work by
uh or money at all
and it's not really clear how the
techniques can be expanded to other
noise models
finally let me point out that our result
also implies an upper bound on the
threshold value for
id noise modeled by different qubit
channels for example in the case of pd
pricing noise
which with probability p maps the state
to the maximally mixed state and with
probability one minus p
keeps the state intact
uh it's known that the quantum capacity
is zero for p strictly greater than one
third therefore
uh in our model voltron is not
achievable for a single time step
which
implies an upper bound of one-third
on the threshold value
uh this bound is actually stronger than
the previous bounds given these earlier
works except
maybe a bound by kampa at all which is
under specific assumptions
but i should say that these results are
not really comparable because
uh
the
models are different
so as i promised earlier i'm going to
very briefly explain the outline of the
argument we use to prove our result
so let's recap the setup
we have a quantum circuit in which
registers in each time step are
partitioned into a and b subsystems the
circuit only acts locally on a and b
and it communicates classically between
the two parts
and
our goal is to show that the
entanglement between the two parts of
the circuit decreases by a constant by a
factor of one minus p to the n
in each time step where p is a constant
only depending on the channel n
so we use two different arguments for
the case when n is unital and when n is
non-united
so a quantum channel is unital if it
maps identity to itself
we show that any non-unitary
unit or cubic channel is slightly
entangled breaking in the sense that it
can be written as a convex combination
of a unitary channel and
an entanglement breaking channel
so a quantum channel's called entangled
breaking if it's uh when when it's
tensored with identity
always maps to several quantum states
so
given this lemma it's easy to see how
the proof goes
so in each time step
with some probability p to the n the
entangled between the two parts of the
circuit is completely destroyed
and we can show that the entanglement is
reduced by a factor of at least one
minus pn
uh in order to show this key lemma we
use the block sphere representation of
cubed states
so that the power operators form a basis
for the set of two by two hermitian
operators with respect to the hilbert
schmidt inner product
uh and uh any single qubit states row uh
written in this basis is represented by
a vector r in r3 which is called the
block vector corresponding to the state
rule
now in this representation
the action of any cubic channel
up to unitary rotations corresponds to
first
rescaling r according to some vector
lambda in r3
and then shifting it by another vector t
in r3
it's easy to check that such a linear
map is trace preserving uh but for it to
be completely positive
t and lambda need to satisfy
some constraints
and it turns out that for unital cubic
channels we have necessary and
sufficient conditions for this
so in this representation a linear map n
is unital if and only if t is equal to
zero
and theorem one here by ruska at all
states that
uh up to unitary rotations the set of uh
unit2qubit channels can be described by
a tetrahedron in r3
with corners that are given by these
four points
and these points actually correspond to
conjugation by paulia operators
and and the final ingredient
we need is another theorem by ruskai
which states that
a unit of cubic channel is entirely
breaking
if lambda in this representation belongs
to the convex hall of these
six points and these are exactly the
midpoints of the corners of the
tetrahedron in theorem one
so so this this convex hole is an
octahedron which is inscribed inside the
tetrahedron
now
using this geometric picture it's easy
to see that any unital channel can be
written
a unit or cubic channel can be written
in in the form of the lemma
and the constant p is easily computable
using a simple
linear program
next we consider non-unital noise
[Music]
we first need the following
definition the trace known contraction
coefficient of a quantum channel n is
defined as
the supremum over pairs of density
operators drawn sigma of the ratio given
by
the trace distance between n of rho and
n of sigma
divided by the trace distance between
draw and sigma
uh so so a quantum channel n decreases
the distance between uh any two input
states by at least at the trace of n
and uh as i mentioned earlier a quantum
channel n is called strictly contractive
if data trace of n is
strictly less than one
you can show that non-unital cubic
channels are examples of strictly
contractive quantum channels and uh this
can be seen for example
using the representation
in the previous slide
now
the idea in this case is to use this
fact
to show that the noise in the circuit
decreases the distance from the set of
separable states in each time step
but
we need this contractivity property
for
tensor powers of the noise channel
unfortunately
in general
if a quantum channel is strictly
contractive its tensor powers are not
necessarily strictly contracted
for cubic channels however this is not
the case
in fact we show that for any non-unital
cubic channel n
there exists a constant p depending on n
such that the trace known contraction
coefficient of n tensor n is at most one
minus p to the n
i believe that uh the fact that tensor
powers of strictly contractive cubic
channels are strictly contracted was
actually known before
but our contribution is that
is this this quantitative statement
about how the contraction coefficient
behaves on their tensor powers
uh to show this
we prove a general upper bound on the
trace known contraction coefficient in
the d dimensional case
uh the bound is in terms of the minimum
eigenvalue of the troy operator
corresponding to
the composition of the channel with its
adjoint
defined here
if you're not familiar with this
just think of it as a psd operator
defined by the channel
so
what is nice about this bound is that it
behaves nicely under tensor powers of
channels so
this operator for n sensor n
is equal to the operator corresponding
to n
tensor then times uh so the eigenvalues
also behave as we want under
chanceurization
and uh
we can also show that for
or cubic channels this operator is full
like so
the minimum eigenvalue is strictly
positive
okay
so
this would have been sufficient to prove
what we want
if the noise were acting only on
or acting on all the subsystems
but in our model the classical
subsystems are noisy
intuitively this shouldn't change
anything because
uh these are classical systems and
indeed uh we have the same behavior
but for technical reasons
we need to use
the chi-square divergence as our
distance measure
instead of the trace distance
in order to deal with these
noise-free classical systems
we also
use this property that
chi-squared contraction coefficient is
bounded above by the trace known
contraction coefficient
where
the contraction coefficient in this case
is defined as before
with trace distance replaced by
a chi-square divergence
so
to summarize
in this work we studied
noisy quantum circuits and we proved a
lower bound on the space overhead of
ball turns schemes
and we tried to address some of the
limitations of the previous results
we consider a model with minimal
assumptions uh we allow classical
computation to be
free and noiseless and
so as a result our results apply to
adaptive protocols
composed of a hybrid of classical and
quantum computation
and
our results also apply to the low noise
regime
as well as the noise levels beyond the
threshold value
and along the way we also proved an
exponential bound on the maximum length
of computation against amplitude damping
noise
uh which was posed as an open question
uh
earlier by
ben orton
so let me also mention a few open
questions
so we have two bounds in terms of the
circuit depth and weights
ideally we would want a single bound
which captures the dependence on both
another direction is
investigating the effect of
adding geometric locality restrictions
in the circuit model
so in our model we are low arbitrary
gates that act potentially in all the
registers however uh in real-world
implementations
we are always restricted in the number
of qubits that we can interact
simultaneously and we can only act
locally in qubits
the question is with this additional
restriction
can we show stronger lower bounds on the
necessary overhead
and finally we can consider a queued
case
and noise channels in higher dimensions
so our techniques
give us a similar bounds for a subset of
noise channels in a given dimension
but
they're not applicable to all conduit
channels
and with this i'd like to conclude my
presentation
thanks for your attention